yes would you like a wrapper taxes whoa
thrilling great what what about Texas I
know it's on everyone's mind does a tax
season but what specifically about taxes
no that's I asked you the question
personal income taxes okay
imaginative great personal income taxes
guys we've set a really low bar it's
only gonna get better from now on if you
are in the front section through bond
that's not there yet
children on leashes trying to see okay
cool yeah I mean real popular over here
ah do you have children
you're 19 okay I know I mean as well as
a beach beam I'm from Manchester in the
UK you should have had like three
children by now
I've got a lot of friends from the score
I grew up they say our grandparents
already that's a true fact they're very
happy with their lives actually
so children aren't leashes are you here
with your parents then did you keep your
child on a leash no well you don't know
they could have just made you forget
about it just like quick little you know
open the car door on your head you know
remember that you have on a leash you
never you never did it no and then is
this you the mother of one is it yeah
did you ever keep your child on a leash
only a little brother okay I hesitate to
ask
he's not here right now I see no good
you live off eventually you're a lie ok
we'll we'll trust you there we go okay
so personal income taxes children on
leashes let's come to people at the back
of the room what you Iraq that ah thank
you yes yes we've all been longing for a
rap about lawn maintenance we're gonna
get it now it's gonna be great
I don't know it no further questions on
that one thank you guys over here so far
it has escalated in quality of
suggestions then de-escalated and now
we're gonna try and see which way we go
oh there were two so what did you say
Ash Wednesday ah Wow a lot of you knew
what that was well done so yeah yeah I
mean okay I thought the Easter was very
much like a British tradition but
obviously it's over here okay cool good
on you all so I'm just gonna keep
looking at you because my gosh your
chest oh oh mama
no don't close it up don't be shy I love
that the kind of guy that's like I'm
gonna unbuttons and then with someone
comments on it oh no dude objectify me
no you got those boy titties I like them
they're nice I'm married to a woman but
men are also very attractive right
someone at the back said something I
think you said fiftieth birthday is that
right okay
oh dear okay um before I continue this
club did they pay you for the birthday
package no okay so you should have
coughed up more if you are this
interaction no so is it your 50th
birthday oh yes it is and what's your
name Andy hi Andy how's it how's it
going awesome gosh you are like no other
50 year old I've ever ever met if I met
a 50 year old I was at how's it going he
was like awesome I'd be like oh you
definitely divorced your wife left your
kids and bought a sports car that's what
happened oh you watch me on YouTube all
the time oh that's really nice I'm sorry
I've been mean to you Andy you're my
favorite person in here right
screw you with your man boobs
I don't worry I am still taking at
Wednesday but so Andy it's your 50th
birthday what is your favorite thing
about being 50 I know you've only just
turned it so it's quite a big question
really it's gonna be what's the best
thing that happened to you today
I found a parking spot yeah that happens
when you're 50 what are you looking
forward to about being 50 is the
question
Oh like be like being able to say your
half-a-century that's quite cool I like
that well congratulations and long may
it continue although I should remind you
the average lifespan of a man is in the
upper seventies women alike we get paid
less beget more time to spend it so I
mean economically that doesn't work out
we it means we get more money per year
so okay to remind you all of the
suggestions we had personal income taxes
we had children on leashes lawn care
half a century I guess an Andy peeing 50
and Ash Wednesday from what's your name
handsome man Kevin oh it's a shame isn't
it
it's a shame
I wanted you to be something like kinda
like you know handsome name but it's
okay it's not my fault the babies are
ugly so you give them ugly names you
didn't pop out with like perfectly
chiseled pectoral did you are you
applauding me being mean about your name
Rick you know you can change it it's
really cheap I wish i cuz I'm called
Chris I wish I was I'd change my name
but just to Chris with a K I think that
would be cool all right Chris with a K
like I think I'd look like you if I was
Chris with okay but now I look like this
cuz I'm Chris with a see all right this
then after all that kerfuffle is gonna
be a freestyle rap there's a rap made up
on the spot based entirely on those
suggestions never been seen before will
never be seen again and do not worry
it'll not be anywhere near as
atrociously bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be so let's say let's drop that
beat and let's have some fun you excited
oh yeah this is gonna be fun it's going
so high hold it from the back sitting on
the chair you were like guys watch this
say long hair I wanna make sure I get my
whole brass freak by it down three
millimeter then every I've got the
mechanical tool lets cut the little
nails it makes all the other gardeners
cool I never failed cuz i impale all of
the steel other gardeners get angry and
their blog post they wish their lawn was
manicured his mind people watch my
garden and go down
squeeze him not you come on let's
celebrate like a mad wedding a ruby one
it's really clear it means you celebrate
those 50 years right
right at the back he feels lucky like a
water Vegas put it all on black half a
century it was meant to be I was born
fifty years ago with my placenta to came
out it was after me a wild like a rapid
whitewater raft all a day having fun
Andy standing up everybody else's like
when the heck see sure enough who
brought a a flower this we might
complain me but come round my house but
not on Ash Wednesday choose a day before
it's a bow one mate row Jews day we can
cook up older pancakes
Ash Wednesday is where you put your
thumb in the heart you can put it on
your bed clean up with the forehead
cross residue you look at Jesus think
I'm glad it was you you died for my sins
the son of God you will pray to did what
sent down was your job you died for sins
and then were revived
Shrove Tuesday a verb that would be
shrived thank you very much for watching
please watch more playlists stairs
subscribe here like comment all those
things shouting bye